foreign
[Music]
hi everyone
thank you for coming to Cloud next this
is this session is cloud run firestore
and Firebase serverless At Your Service
now the English expression to be at your
service means to provide help whenever
needed and serverless is here to help
your product be successful
I am Sarah Ford I'm a developer
relations engineer on the serverless
team
and I will be joined by Sylvester main
who is a cloud of run customer at
orderly health
so in this talk you're going to learn
about Cloud run which is Google Cloud's
easiest and most convenient place to run
back-end code written in any language
and you will see in the demos how Cloud
run and Firebase work great together
now Cloud run is designed for scale with
cost efficiency in mind which we'll see
throughout this talk and lastly you'll
see a few demos including Cloud run jobs
which is you could think of clavering
jobs as cron jobs for the cloud and also
you'll hear Sylvester's customer story
so Firebase is Google's app development
platform for web mobile and game apps
and it is awesome
with Firebase you get a Firebase hosting
you get manage user authentication and
you get a nosql database called
firestore because you don't know what
the seek the schema is going to look
like tomorrow much less in a few hours
so as you grow you're going to want your
own you want Dynamic websites you're
going to want your own apis you're going
to want Ai and ml services but you don't
want to manage all that growing
infrastructure you have things to do so
in this talk you'll see how Firebase and
Cloud run work great together
now with serverless you're not managing
physical servers but you find yourself
now managing scaling
when you go to serverless
you'll find that
you'll get to focus on what's core to
your business which is app your
application development and with
serverless you get performance
monitoring Straight Out of the Box
here's a different way to look at
serverless so this is a Google Cloud
customers uh website the traffic from
this from this customer's website used
with permission and here it's a you can
see the consumer traffic it it comes in
highs and lows it's for it's wavy it
comes in bursts right so if you want to
be able to handle this traffic you have
to open provision the areas in the dark
blue to be able to handle that that
traffic
but what if a famous uh influencer
mentions your site you you don't want
those uh that traffic to you know those
customers that have a bad experience
but you also don't want to over
provision because that's not fun either
you're having to pay for all that dark
blue area
scaling can be challenging if you want
it to be cost efficient because you have
to make sure capacity closely tracks the
demand
or you could let serverless handle Auto
scaling for you and to use a calculus
analogy because you cannot have a Google
talk without a math joke
you think of serverless as paying for
the area under the Curve
so with Cloud run you get to run
containers in the fully managed
environment you get an HTTP endpoint
including load balancing out of the box
and Clause 1 implements K native so
anything that you can put into a
container you can run on cloud run
and lastly there is no cluster
management so no manually managing
scaling up and down
now although Cloud run is offering all
this doing all this Auto scaling for you
there's additional fine tuning you can
do as well in case you even know of like
a particular Black Friday Cyber Monday
high traffic spiky type of traffic event
or you have certain workloads
and one of those functioning is minimum
instances so let's say that you scale
that zero so you have no traffic here
because if you're paying for what you're
using you're paying us you're paying for
what you use and then traffic comes to
your Cloud run service so Cloud one is
going to spin up an instance and
cloudman will keep that instance warm
for 15 minutes for free
and then scale back down if there's no
traffic within that time frame but let's
say you know there's something around
the corner there's going to be a high
traffic event you can set a minimum
number of instances warm to handle that
traffic they will not scale down
and I want to be clear on terminology
with the cloud run defines concurrency
as the number of requests a single
instance can handle at any given time by
default clavron sets this to 80. you can
configure this as needed
all right let's talk about billing so
with Cloud run for billing you pay for
the CPU and memory that you use you do
not pay for the number of requests that
you handle and you do not pay when the
instance is kept uh idle as we mentioned
in that 15 minutes uh in that 15-minute
state so you're paid for the so here in
the blue the two blue bars I overlapped
you see that you're paid for the
combination of those two requests for
the CPU and memory that you use combined
and also let's call out uh in the bottom
of the chart the CPU always allocated so
when an I when an instance is idle in
that state where uh it's being kept one
way and just to see with them up to 15
minutes and more traffic is going to
come in before a spell scaled down Cloud
on will reduce the CPU to conserve
resources
but if you know I need this Ray to go at
all times to CPU you can also enable
that
the CPU always allocated
so for the first demo we're going to
talk about you're going to see how you
can use minimum instances to keep
traffic ready to go but let's do a slide
overview illustration first
all right so let's talk about what a
cool start is let's say that you're
starting up your service there's certain
things you want to do in this
utilization time like connect to a
database or maybe you have a a
computational heavy method that you want
to Cache that result you don't want to
do that every single time a request
comes in you want to Cache that and
reuse that that's yeah when possible so
we're going to refer to that as a quote
cold start but
once the instance is warm any request to
go to that instance up to 15 minutes can
reuse that connection or reuse that
cache data
but again if you know of a Black Friday
Cyber Monday event around the corner you
can just set minimum instances to be
available and here upset 2 minimum
instances as you'll see in the demo that
are ready to go so they're not going to
scale down even after 15 minutes even if
there's no traffic
all right so it's demos all right
so the first demo you're going to see is
how Cloud run does automatic Auto
scaling and also you'll see minimum
instances then you'll see how cloudron
and fires are the nosql database works
great together with auto scaling and
then lastly you'll see uh Cloud run jobs
let's say like you just have a task or a
job you want to run you don't need to
handle like HTTP requests you just want
to run a task or a job
you'll see how you can do that with
Cloud run jobs
and I have these sorts of videos if you
come to the Innovation Hive uh Booth I'm
happy to pull out the laptop and show
you these on on my laptop as well
and let me skip the first video going
all right
Okay so
in this first video you're going to in
this first demo you're going to see
how I have a computational heavy method
and it's going to Cache it it's going to
take five seconds to to run so you're
going to see how you can use minimum
instances to reduce that latency by
reusing it in future
requests that come in I'm using go
laying or using go language just to show
that if you can put it in a container
you can run it in Cloud run and then uh
yeah I'm catching that in global scope
and also I'm using main which just goes
um
anything that's in Maine is going to be
initialized in that cold start
so here in the hello world uh request
Handler I am calling the heavy uh the
computational heavy method I'm using
lazy initialization which means I'm only
called a method if and when I need to
and notice the Emojis I have a cold I
have a warm emojis throughout this demo
you'll see that in later
and then lastly to simulate a heavy
computational method I'm just doing a
five second sleep
all right I'm going to use gcloud run
deploy command but notice that there's
no Docker file on the uh
in the in the in the files
this is because I'm going to let Cloud
run use build packs to build the
container based on the source code that
I have available and buildpax implements
the cloud native build pack
specification so I tell cloudron Cloud
run deploy command where's my source is
in the local current directory indicated
by dot then I'll call this demo one
scale from zero because we're just
throwing the service up using the
defaults and then it says allow
unauthenticated invocations so I'm going
to say yes to mimic a public facing API
and now it's starting to build a
container
and I'm going to fast forward a couple
minutes
and now now that my container or my
service is running I have a service URL
at the bottom and I'm going to send
traffic to it using an open source tool
called Hey for just for a low generation
I'm going to send 10 000 requests 100 at
a time
so this is hey it's only 10 000 requests
100 at a time but remember on the cloud
run side it can handle up to 80 by or 80
by default for each instance now it's
going to take up at least five seconds
because of that cool start
because of that uh initial like that the
first time we were calling that
computational heavy method and we could
see that too in the histogram
um we actually see it 100 requests were
sent to code starts or affected by Cold
starts it has a time of 6.5 seconds
every other time I've done this video I
got 5.5 seconds this time when I
recorded I got 6.5 I think it's because
I was recording from home and my
internet service provider was a bit
slower and also I'm not using my laptop
here I was using my laptop to record so
whatever might have been happening also
in the laptop side too not a true
benchmarking to us but you get the idea
all the other requests indicated by P
the P95 is
0.0881 whereas P99 is 6.1
okay so now in those instances it's warm
I'm going to send it the same amount of
traffic 10 000 requires 100 at the time
same endpoint NOW Watch What Happens
let's take a peek at the pay attention
to that P99 value now we see the slowest
request was 0.27
and
the P99 time was oops let me back up two
seconds uh maybe two more seconds we
have P99 was 0.1131 seconds because it
got to reuse no one had a cold start
they all got to use that cash value
because the instance was kept one
but again and then here I'm in the cloud
run service I refresh I see the new one
I just deployed
and if I go to the logs I mentioned the
Emoji
I am a big fan of emoji driven
development so here we're going to
filter by cold start or by cold oh and
nothing like showing your frequently
used emojis you know in a recording on
stage on next
and here we see three instances so we
had three cold starts so we spun up
Cloud one spun up three and just for
completeness I wanted to show those 100
requests that were affected by those
cold starts by using a warm emoji
yeah Emoji driven development is fun all
right but now I mentioned
if you know that there's going to be
something around the corner you can set
minimum instances so here I have it set
to two
and I'm going to send
um yeah I'm just copying copying the
cloud run service URL and then I'm going
to Arrow up delete the old uh the first
call run URL I'm going to replace it
with the minimum instances Cloud run
service URL and blast it again 10 000
requests 100 at a time and again pay
attention to pin 99 value everything's
warm because I kept them warm and here
we see
that if P99 was 0.18 and
it's going to back up two seconds to
show one thing I try to remember to say
this is important notice that it said
four hours ago
so that it was not within that 15 minute
this is this was kept um worn for a
while
jump
back in
all right what a lot about 10 minutes go
by because I wanted to show you the
dashboards so this is the first service
the scale from zero where we just
deployed a new container you see that it
spun up the three cool Stars we saw that
with the cold emoji and then you can see
the grab of idle how it's going
they're spinning down because there was
no traffic within that 15 minute time
frame but check out what happens within
instances we see that two and crusts
were kept idle until it got traffic it
got blasted by that hay traffic and then
you see that is switch oops and then it
switched to um active
so does demo one using Min instances
all right so demo two what I you're
going to see is how you can use
firestore to automatically scale with
Cloud run so what I did at the firestore
is I took my computational heavy method
I ripped all that code out and replaced
it with a query to firestore
and then the bottom corner it says that
it has one one hundred thousand or one
one hundred thousand three
uh um Rose to a collection called
employees
so again I'm using this pretty much the
same code but in main I'm initializing
the connection to the database because I
don't need each request Handler doing
its own connection
and then
here I am querying all the employees in
that 100 000 row collection that are
from New Orleans or New Orleans or New
Orleans I can do that all day and yeah
how many other employees are from there
so each request is going to do that
query to 100 000 rows
and in the interest of time I'm going to
just skip ahead from the gcloud we're on
deploy you've seen that now so I'm still
using the defaults I just want to show
the default out of box behavior and I'm
going to send again I just like these
numbers 10 000 requests 100 at a time
and then I'm going to use that uh
new Cloud run URL or Cloud run service
URL
so each request is going to do that
query
and here's the next room is getting
excited too
and we see that P99 is 0.4288
so the only customization the only
change I made to firestore was just
tweaking the production rules for
rewrite for or tweaking the rules for
rewrite to a production database that's
the only everything else is out of the
box
and then the final demo
is Claiborne jobs
so let's say you don't need like let's
say like you just have a task or a job
that you want to run to completion
you can see that the last entry is
August 7th and I just want to see how
many new employees joined last week this
time there's no entry Handler there's
everything is in Maine because we're
just going to query the database from
start to end
here I'm just want to say hey give me
all the employees to joined last week
and this time is doing gcloud run deploy
I'm going to say gcloud run jobs deploy
because this is a job
I give it as a source location
a given the name demo three but notice
that there was no prompt for
unauthenticated invocations because
you're not handling requests you're just
running the job
and now that is I can say gcloud run
jobs execute and then the name of my
server my job
and so it's running now and it's
querying to find out all the employees
and it's actually writing it into that
weekly report so here we can see August
14th has 140 you you uh user or new
employees was updated and I can go to
this link in the terminal
to go straight to the cloud run jobs
page for that uh for that job notice
that it says tax zero I could also do
batch processing and have multiple tasks
here I only use one it has zero but one
of the things that's also awesome about
tasks and collabor and jobs is that you
can have long running jobs you can have
jobs that run for 24 hours so each task
can go up to 24 hours
and then each task has its own logs just
again for completeness the engineering
me you see they logged 140 new employees
just like in the database and then
lastly I'll show you the uh the con part
of crime jobs for the cloud I can use uh
you can use a cloud scheduler to
schedule this
and I'm going to put it every Sunday
night at 11 59 pm to trigger This Cloud
run job
so that concludes demo three Cloud run
jobs cron jobs for the cloud and now I'm
going to invite Sylvester on stage
[Applause]
all right
hi I'm Sylvester an engineer at orderly
Health
where we have been working to create the
most accurate view of Provider data
possible
orderly Health has a variety of products
available that help you
assess your data needs help you automate
your ingestion and ingestion enhance
your data or we could help you build
your own provider directory and manage
it
but how do we do this
serverless
so our history is basically a story of
how business
use serverless Technologies to build
adapt and scale
over time we use cloud functions to get
ideas out quickly we use cloud run to
consolidate things when it was
convenient and we use bigquery to push
down our workloads so we didn't have to
manage all of that spark infrastructure
and things like that you normally do in
ETL processes
so here's the story
in the beginning there was Sean
and some data scientists
and they follow the normal route to grab
data from here and there they saved it
all over the place on their laptops and
they manually toil to get the data sets
built that served our customers
and it worked and the customers were
happy but if anyone ever asks oh how did
you go from input X to Output Y at time
Z you had to go spelunking through
random data science notebooks and
laptops and folders and it wasn't fun
so we hired some Engineers to automate
Sean
the first thing we did was we took all
the data and we pushed it up into the
cloud in the g into a Google cloud
storage and set up some standard rules
for all right this is how you name your
buckets and paths so everyone's on the
same page
and then we did the same thing on cloud
SQL
that worked with the data in the cloud
backed up resilient and accessible by
everybody and consistent we were able to
now focus on automating the ETL
processes that we had going
um but we overshot a little bit we
focused on building software instead of
pipelines and what we ended up building
was like this complicated bespoke thing
where we were building our own
Frameworks and stuff like that and it
made it difficult to enhance and to
debug and to expand so we had to take a
step back and think like
what are we doing
are we in the business of making data or
Reinventing the cloud
data
so we took that that system that we had
built we didn't throw it out we took all
the lessons that we learned and the and
the good processes that we figured out
and started to think how can we simplify
this
one of the first things we did was we
went from ETL to elt
so we could get all the data into the
system by a simple means it's necessary
and we sunk it into our data warehouse
which was bigquery which like I said is
was useful because I didn't have to
manage my own Warehouse or build it
myself from scratch and then we with all
the data in one place we could start to
ingest it and process it and start to
develop our in-house methodology our
algorithms that we use to form that best
view of the world
of the provider of data world
and once we had that and we wanted to
serve the data to our customers we
cached it all over in elasticsearch that
allowed us to
to back our apis with a simple
searchable interface and then we just
spun up a endpoint
by a simple means necessary which Cloud
functions allowed us to do
over time we started realizing
everything's data
therefore everything's a data pipeline
therefore
you know the same practices for
ingestion or outjestion and the
methodology they're all similar so we
were able to automate all the things
and actually we were able to consolidate
some of the practices to go faster
at this point in time we had a pretty
thin method for doing our elt our
ingestion our digestion all the things
you'd want to do when you're dealing
with data which is
kind of a big deal here
um
and we started expanding our offerings
once those expanded our endpoints
started to
to expand as well and at that point we
took a step back and said well
there's a lot of replication here like
we're duplicating logic so we could we
should start to consolidate this somehow
we thought well we could extract
commonalities put it into libraries but
then we'd have to inherit the overhead
of managers CID CI CD systems pip repos
the life cycles of those things
or we could go the lazy the efficient
route and consolidate it into one
service
so we did that we Consolidated it into
one service so that all the common code
was there everything else sat on top of
it and it was pretty easy to do because
you know Cloud functions are basically
well we're using python it's essentially
like
a single flask endpoint running on top
of Cloud run under the hood anyways so
the consolidation was trivial same code
less of it
so yeah
essentially
our story was a history of building
adapting and scaling and using service
Technologies allowed us to do that
because we didn't have to to manage the
infrastructure the scaling the the all
the things all the things you get with a
serverless solution
you know Cloud functions allowed us to
spend get our ideas out quickly
Cloud run let us consolidate or run
bigger jobs
bigquery became our Workhorse for our
data transformation loads and things
like that
so
yeah that worked out
since the beginning
Google was with us helping us out via
the startup Google for startup Cloud
program
their credits allowed us to focus on
building instead of worrying about
software costs
we had experts there to answer questions
for us
and
whenever we had a problem or an idea we
had people to spitball with and they
would they would give suggestions which
was really helpful and we also got a few
sneak peeks which was nice
so
I'm going to hand this back to Sarah
if you want more information about that
program you can scan the QR code
thank you
[Applause]
okay so what's next if you're interested
in club run or Claver and Joss we have
quick starts
and if you're already in the Firebase
ecosystem and you want to try out Cloud
run Firebase has stocks specifically for
serverless for cloud functions and Cloud
run and there's also some other talks as
well at Cloud next
okay again takeaways uh Cloud run is
designed for scale uh with cost
efficiency it's my in mind and you also
get additional uh fine-tuning
um Cloud Runner is great firestore is
great but you know what's better
together cloud cloud run and firestore
all right Firebase and then also uh
collar and jobs is John uh Crown Club
room jobs is cron jobs for the cloud and
remember up to 24 hours processing time
again your feedback is appreciated uh
please uh if you haven't already
download the app let us know your
feedback and thank you
foreign